Responding with web pages is great, but
sometimes all that needs to be
communicated is information.
For example, let's say that there's
a web application out there called Yum
that wants to collect
our restaurant menus and
advertise them to mobile clients
based on their location.
Free advertising, all right!
This app wants to see the restaurants
and menus available in our database but
doesn't really need to
parse through HTML or
waste bandwidth receiving CSS files.
It just wants the data.
For this reason,
developers have created APIs, or
Application Programming Interfaces,
that allow external applications to use
public information our
apps want to share,
without all the bells and whistles.
When an API is communicated over the
Internet, following the rules of HTTP,
we call this a restful API.
One of the most popular ways of sending
data with a restful architecture is with
a format called JSON, which stands for
JavaScript object notation.
JSON uses attribute value pairings
which are delimited by a colon.
Brackets are used to
encapsulate individual objects.
Let's start coding to add this
JSON feature to our application.
Before we write the JSON
function in our Flask menu app,
let's first open up the database
setup.pi and add a decorator method.
This serializable function will help
define what data we want to send across,
and put it in a format
that Flask can easily use.
Flask has a built-in package,
called jsonify,
that will allow us to easily configure
an API endpoint for our application.
I will go ahead and import this
package now in my project.py file.
For this lesson we are only going to
focus on using a get request to get
a collection of restaurant menu items.
But know that other types of
requests can be implemented as well.
I will now create a route similar
to my restaurant menu page
with /JSON at the end.
I then create a function and
name it restaurant menu JSON and
then perform the same query as
in my restaurant menu class.
But instead of returning a template,
I will return this jsonify class and
use this loop to serialize
all of my database entries.
Now, if I save and go to local host
port 5000/restaurants/1/menu/json,
I return with the pure data form
of my menu in a format that can
easily be read by humans and
easily parsed by other computers